now if gratulations on this award
generation award huh just turned 40 yes
I know you're all about looking forward
planning for the future yes but when you
look back yeah on your career so far
like where do you see this generation
we're kind of fitting in um I mean it's
a great question you know it's still
it's still pretty dope to me like I said
to them and the previous interview is
very humbling to be given such an award
I opening make me realize just how much
you've actually done in your career so
when I look back I go wow I'm extremely
fortunate extremely blessed to have been
able to do things that I've done more
importantly to have the fans to receive
it for the years that they've done it so
you know it's about not getting
comfortable staying true to the dream to
the craft and still trying to break new
ground while at the same time accepting
the moments in and actually taking them
in and not just speeding past right well
in terms of not getting comfortable had
a huge hit with the upside kind of more
dramatic role ya know you're shooting
you've been a muncher all for a while
yeah yeah I think that's a more serious
role much more serious right much
something you wanted to do more with the
drama side you know it's not do more of
it's just it's just simply progress
we're not thinking anything that you do
in life you always want to go up you
don't want to go backwards so anytime
that I can take to pretty much show my
audience that I'm always working on my
craft I'm always trying to do more to do
new is is is something that I take
advantage of so this is an inkling and a
glimpse of what's to come I'm not not
going to do comedy I'm still going to do
comedy and I'm just gonna switch it up
and just throw some some mind blows in
there occasionally it's off the French
picking up any French absolutely not but
I'm sure
come on jelly whoo that's good so
yesterday is the Blake Griffin here's
just did that video in the ice baths
which was like oh yeah yeah how was that
was that colder than you expected I was
always cold it's always cold but Blake
Griffin is a great guy great guest I
know that he was doing some stuff here
so I'm not sure how I went but I'm quite
sure was well amazing very personally
guys I'm laughing because so I asked him
if you had a message for you okay to
give to you you can tell him why is me
at my gallery last night obviously this
hugely successful Netflix special then
yeah few months ago where's everyone's
time with Eddie Murphy yeah possible for
$70 we think about if any possibly doing
stand-up again he's huge if anywhere to
touch the stage and this generation
today got to see it's it's massive you
know you're looking at a man who has
done so much I know for me and my career
I'm able to do two things because of the
doors and he opened so I'm in all of it
I hope it happens and if it does trust
me I'll be front row it to the side I
make sure that I'm present on a day
awesome
you